hey youtubers is Charlie so this week
everybody is back arrow flash Supergirl
legends of tomorrow all start shooting
again this is mostly going to be about
those first couple of episodes but the
actors have started to tease things so
the flash and arrow started filming this
week or start filming this week the
flash starts on Wednesday arrow starts
today Stephen Amell is like hey we're
back we're filming I'm in the tuxedo
so I'm gonna talk a little bit about
what's going to be happening in those
first episodes there are a few things
that we know about few things that are
still a mystery like the flashpoint
storyline so this weekend Stephen Amell
was misquoted talking about flashpoint
when people were like is it going to
affect arrow and he's like sure but he
said it sarcastically people took it the
wrong way
so people were like oh my god flashpoint
is majorly going to affect the arrow
storyline and he had to clarify so he's
like no no I have no idea how much
flashpoint is going to affect arrow so
I'll just reiterate what I said way way
back when they first announced
flashpoint what I think is going to
happen just because logistically it's so
difficult even to have minor crossovers
is that they will only address the
change timeline when flash stuff is
happening on arrow
so like when Felicity or Diggle or
Oliver says something or references the
flash characters like Barry was talking
about this the other day on the phone
that's when they'll talk about
flashpoint stuff otherwise the
characters themselves wouldn't know
anything's different if the timelines
been shaped like Oliver wouldn't have
memories of the previous timeline as far
as we know the only person who would be
able to detect the difference in time
lines would be Cisco so what exactly is
going to be happening in the first
couple of episodes so in the first
episode of arrow which starts filming
today Stephen Amell is probably filming
mayor Oliver Queen scenes like him
schmoozing with all his constituents
just like dealing with the day-to-day of
being mayor but because each new season
of arrow and flash typically pick up
like three months in the timeline later
that presents like a big question mark
for where the flash starts in episode 1
because typically the flash would be
like three months later like at the
start of season two Barry had been away
from team flash he'd been trying to
rebuild the city they kind of split up
for a while like in the way that team
arrow is split up right now the huge
difference
this year is already like a parent like
the minute he saved his mother
everyone's like oh my god he did the
flashpoint thing he's going to go back
and it's all going to be different so
what they're probably going to have to
do on the flash that's different from
arrow episode one is have like a short
sequence at the beginning of the episode
where he goes back it's different in
then they flash forward instead of like
arrow where they can just immediately
pick up three months later like they
have to address what happens right after
Barry saves his mother and goes back so
like I said even though season three of
the flash is like the flashpoint season
it's going to look very different from
the actual plot of flashpoint it's
really just like the thematic beats like
the collateral damage that Barry causes
by going back and messing with the
timeline saving his mother so like in
this versions like the TV shows version
of flashpoint Barry will still have
flash powers because they already did
the flashpoint moment where he loses his
powers then gets them back like he does
in the flashpoint comic book so what
about the big villains and the new
characters they announced on arrow
they're like two big new characters or
three if you include Chad Coleman from
Walking Dead so starting with the flash
we have Tom Felton he is probably going
to get introduced the same way Jay
Garrick got introduced last year not in
the very first episode maybe in the
second or third episode because they
just announced the character they're
shooting this week so I'm assuming that
episode 1 will be dedicated to Barry
just getting used to all the things that
are different it'll be like oh my god
look at what's changed because of what
you've done then in episode 2 they can
dedicate more time to introducing this
new character they haven't really
confirmed which episode he's going to
debuted I'm just assuming that most of
episode 1 is going to be dedicated to
setting up what's different about each
of the big main characters like what's
different about Cisco what's different
about Caitlin and all the other
characters answering what's going on
with Tom Cavanagh is character is he
going to be another version of Harrison
wells is it going to be earth - Harrison
wells on the arrow side of things
episode 1 does it really need to worry
about that they have a little bit easier
time because at the end of the last
season team arrow just kind of went
their separate ways they'll just open
the season touching base with all the
characters what they've been doing the
last three months what they're doing
right now and teeing up the big
vigilantes storyline that's going to be
happening this year the cool thing about
the new season of arrow is that just
like flashpoint
they're kind of using it to reset the
show just a little bit now not in like a
comic book flashpoint way it's not the
change timeline that's resetting the
show it's just that like all the
characters are going to be doing vastly
different things like the dynamic is
going to be relatively similar even
though the individual arcs in like the
way they tell those is going to be a
little bit different I think they're
just they're using the opportunity to do
more of a wire type storyline where like
each character has like a really clearly
defined storyline this season so if you
never watch The Wire like David Simon is
like somebody that a lot of Hollywood
writers worship he and the writers that
show just did a really good job of
giving each of the characters like a
very clearly defined storyline with
motivation like you really understood
what each of the characters goals were
what they were working towards I think
that's the real challenge for arrow and
the flash is like does each character
have a clearly defined story art will
you at the end of the season be able to
say that like each character's story
line while separate from the others was
able to contribute in some way to the
macro art so we actually know a little
bit more about with the macro arc is in
arrow season 5 the city has gone to
vigilantes have risen up and are
cleaning up their city but in a very
Punisher type way like bodies dropping
left and right so Oliver has to make his
city better while also contending with
all these new vigilantes while he
himself was also vigilante like he used
to kill people in season 1 now he's on
the other side of that equation so
that's where most of the drama is you
also have this Chad Coleman character
who is doing a very wire type storyline
where he's consolidating power amongst
all the gangs and physically he's also
very scary-looking so like you would
definitely believe that he'd be able to
kick Oliver to ass on the flash it's a
little bit different because obviously I
think we all expect Barry to have to go
back and allow his mother to die at the
end of the season because that's kind of
what happens during the flashpoint like
Barry has to learn that there are things
that he can't change and he just has to
be okay with that
so like his mother dying is a very bad
thing but that doesn't give him the
right to use his power to change
everyone else's life to suit his so he
in fact going back to save his mother is
just as bad as the reverse-flash going
back to kill his mother although
technically he was trying to kill young
Barry and then killed his mother when
the other flash came back
there's a whole bunch of versions of
berry in that flashback scene so I'll be
really curious if when season one of the
flash picks up back that first episode
berry is still back in that moment in
ages they pick up immediately with his
mother crying like not sure what the
hell's going on because a couple of
crazy superheroes wearing weird pajamas
are in her living room and she doesn't
know what the hell is going on I think
the line that she had when she died
during the end of season one was what
you know when she kind of recognized
berry she's like you look like my father
like she didn't quite know who he was
but he looked familiar so like the last
couple of words in the season 2 finale
he said hers like you're okay
you're fine and then she stops crying
she calms down a little bit so I'll be
interested to see if they choose to
continue that conversation when episode
1 picks up or if they pick up with berry
immediately time traveling back and he
shows up and is like oh my god
everything's different then he sees
everyone and then it flashes forward
three months to catch up with the arrow
timeline because if you've been watching
Game of Thrones this season you know all
about all these different story arcs
going on all over the world not lining
up and it screws with your head in a
major way because you have characters
with the Daenerys storyline that are
moving in a certain pace then you have
the stuff going on up in the north with
Jon Snow it's going on at a very
different pace it's just that it helps
when you have a lot of characters and a
lot of storylines on a TV show like
flash or arrow or really any show that
all move in real time it just makes it
easier to follow a storyline so the
other big thing to get hype about
besides comic-con that's coming in a
couple weeks but you know we'll talk
about that again real soon but Stephen
Amell post on social all the time from
his trailer Grant Gustin said this year
he is also going to do the same thing
not quite in the same way that Stephen
Amell does it but he's going to be
posting more from behind the scenes as
they film episodes
so whenever he ends up talking about if
there's anything cool I will totally
make videos about it usually they're
really good about not spoiling things so
if there are any specific bonus videos
that you guys want me to do for flash
point on the flash or what's you know
what's going on with all the crazy
vigilantes on arrow just let me know in
the comments there'll be some Supergirl
legends of tomorrow stuff to talk about
soon - they've been a little bit quieter
about those shows we know that episode 1
of Supergirl is called The Adventures of
Supergirl so that's like a whole other
thing that I'll talk about in a
different video once we learn a little
bit more about what's going on with that
universe now that it's on the CW I think
that the storytelling will just be more
serialized big payoffs will be a little
bit easier for them to do we have
Superman coming in the first two
episodes he'll be coming it's Clark Kent
but I think he'll also be wearing his
Superman costume the new round of the
giveaway starts now so if you guys don't
know I do a DC giveaway every week it
just runs across all my DC videos all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's just a $20 Amazon gift card
so there'll be more TV stuff happening
later this week that I'll do video for
but they'll also be comic book stuff
like flash rebirth is going on right now
they're introducing the godspeed villain
so I'll explain what's going on with
that
so why you guys wait for my next video
to post you can click here for all my
flash season 3 videos I have some
theories about who the villains going to
be and you can click here to watch
Deadpool troll the at a Batman V
Superman and himself
Deadpool always trolls himself so thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you